you tweeted referring to Phil Ivey as
the goat saying the goat doing goat
things that's a recent tweet so uh can
you make the case for Phil Phil Ivey or
maybe who is the greatest poker player
of all time would you put Phil for me
until someone knocks him off the podium
the king of Poker and the goat is Phil
Ivy okay so and the reason I say that is
I think of Poker as more than just one
game right there's different variants
you know this Holdem Omaha stud triple
draw all these different types of games
and Phil in every Arena
has been dominant whether it was
tournament poker dominated it mixed game
high stakes poker in Bobby's room
dominated online poker against all the
Wizards dominated made millions in every
Arena and you know he sort of took a few
years away from poker with his legal
troubles and things like that but he's
back you know he's been playing in the
High Roller series again and you know he
comes from he's Cut From a Different
Cloth but he has a tenacity and a focus
that's unparalleled I think when he's in
the zone I mean for lack and this has
nothing to do with race it really has to
do with mannerism but he does remind me
of like a a combination of Michael
Jordan and Tiger Woods in the way that
he approaches it he's very intense yeah
and he outworks everybody you know and
has I think frankly a lot of his
mannerisms do come from them because
he's young watching these guys on TV and
a lot of his ways of being you know is
learned behavior I think probably from
from people like people at the top of
their Sport and people that are Tiger
Woods and Michael Jordan aren't just at
the top of their sport but they kind of
dominate support to some kind of aura
that there's a uniqueness to them
they're not built like us they're not
you know they're not like I wish I I
wish I could have the kind of focus that
Phil Ivey has you know and see
everything that he's saying I just
that's not me you know I I don't have
that and he he does he has that that
Gene whatever it is but they also look
like they're not having that much fun
they're more uh focused on the
Perfection like a dogged pursuit of
perfection and you know that might even
be true it might not be as fun you know
I don't know like I have fun at the
table when you look outwardly look at
someone like maybe he is having a blast
maybe that's just the way that he likes
us like his Tiger Woods having fun when
he's like on 17 about to win a major
doesn't look like it theoretically well
if you look at Michael Jordan I don't
know about Tiger Woods but I think
they're more focused on every single
mistake they make yeah I think they're
more obsessed about not making a mistake
and hating every time they make a
mistake that's probably like 99 of their
mental
uh I think that's part of what makes
them great right they don't look past
the mistake and just let it's whatever
no they're like they they want to
correct it and and yeah there's a
tension almost like a trade-off I wonder
if that's always the case between sort
of greatness and and happiness I
remember huxed who you know when I was a
kid growing up he was like the poker
Idol he won the world championship in
1996 and I was lucky enough to hang out
with him a little bit and he would go
through these streaks where he had an a
game and he had an F game his a game was
unparalleled nobody could beat him right
but his F game was so terrible that he
was just a fish you know he was playing
terribly and I remember him saying and
it was exactly what you're saying he'd
make like one little mistake
right and then he would go off and I was
like why do you do that like you know
your b game would be just fine he's like
well if I'm gonna make a mistake what's
the point
what's the point right I'm trying like
if you can't play Perfect there's no
point in playing at all yeah so he was
that he was extreme in that regard and
the way that he viewed it and depending
on the sport those folks like in chess
certainly the case they that kind of
mindset can destroy you absolutely no
because a sequence of mistakes
like the kind of year you had with the
World Series of Poker can completely
destroy a human being
if if you're not able to see the bigger
picture of it yeah uh you said that Phil
Ivey is the hardest uh your toughest
opponent the the toughest person to play
against why is that and how do you beat
him well because Phil Ivey's just he's
seeing things that nobody else has seen
really like subtle things where I'm
putting my hands where I'm looking you
know my pulse like stuff that I don't
even know I'm giving off he's so engaged
and so focused and has such a just a
he's Fearless right A lot of people you
know they'll play poker and be like you
know what I don't think this guy has it
but do they have the guts do they have
the cajones if you will to actually do
anything about it right and stand up to
this person he does you know I forgot
the hand that you tweeted about the the
goat doing goat things but that wasn't
even that big of a goat hand there's
hands where like there was a famous One
in Australia where the Flop was like
Jack Jack nine
and Phil check raised the Flop with six
seven nothing just absolutely nothing
and the guy re-raised him right I feel
just new he went all in with nothing if
the guy calls he's done he's cooked but
he was so tuned in that this guy's not
strong that he just you know he he did
things like that and it's tough to play
against a guy like that so uh he gets
great reads and is able to execute on
them has the guts to execute on her
he's got experience he's got work ethic
he he also I think one thing I'm
underselling too is his strategic mind
right like I believe that
you know like I said the new age player
they learn how to play through a very
systematic approach okay let's look at
the data the make up a game right now
three cards we each get three cards
Jacks Are Wild sixes are you know
six of Hearts as well right just make up
that game Phil will figure it out
intuitively very very quickly right
without having the answers for him right
so that's like the difference between
the players and my generation we had to
figure this stuff out on our own today
oh I want to know the answer I go ask
the computer and the computer tells me
so I really believe like if you created
a game from scratch that Phil Ivey would
be my horse that I want to play in it
so he is in some sense in tune with some
deeper thing he has what we would what
we used to call card sense